everything the light touches
is our kingdom but a king's time is
ruler
rises and falls like the Sun one day
the Sun was set on my time here
and will rise with you as the new king
[Music]
remember hey everybody its charlie Happy
Thanksgiving we just got a live-action
trailer for The Lion King remake that
Jon Favreau is doing he's working on
this while he's doing the Mandalorians
Star Wars TV series they've changed some
of the cast from the original animated
movie but for instance Mufasa
you probably recognize James Earl Jones
voice some of them are coming back so
let's break it down there's a new round
of that imax ticket giveaway - all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video the
cool thing about this trailer that they
released is is actually meant to mirror
the original trailer they released for
the 1994 animated movie
[Music]
shopper shot is the exact same trailer
it just his announcement ceremony
announcing him as the heir apparent the
future king my son has been born let's
announce him to the world you get a
little bit of the extra footage from
later in the movie though with him sort
of putting his feet in his father's paw
prints you get the lead up to the Mufasa
death scene in the canyon and you get
the voiceover remember who you are which
happens much later in the film and you
see the very end of the movie the adult
version of Simba who has reclaimed the
throne so they're actually kind of
showing you the whole movie which is
kind of funny because people always
complain about that but you've already
seen this if you've seen the animated
movie the fun of watching this is just
seeing it done in live-action and it
actually looks pretty spectacular the
difference between this and their last
big live-action remake of a classic
animated film The Jungle Book which was
also directed by Jon Favreau is it the
jungle book required that Mowgli be a
full-blown live human person interacting
with all these CG creatures and for the
most part there really aren't humans
inside the Lion King story so you don't
have to worry about that so everything
looks kind of the same from a CG
perspective so there's nothing to
potentially take you out but they
actually did a good job with the Jungle
Book and I think Jon Favreau sort of
perfected the technique of doing these
live-action remakes during that so from
a technical perspective this just seems
like an evolution of what you saw during
Jungle Book so regardless of how you
feel about the stories it should look
even better if you didn't see it a
little while ago they announced some of
the cast the only person you hear
speaking in the trailer is James Earl
Jones he's really one of the only
high-profile actors that they're
bringing back to reprise his original
character but James Earl Jones I mean
you got to bring him back he's one of
the most iconic voiceover actors in
history biggest changes obviously donald
glover playing adult Simba they have a
different actor playing young Simba for
that first little bit in the film until
you do the time jump to where he's grown
up after he's run away
they have beyonce playing Nala obviously
that's a big upgrade over the original
film she would tell idea for is playing
scar so they're not bringing back Jeremy
Irons even though his version of scar
was great I feel like he does evil
really well alfre woodard is playing
Sarabi Simba's mother John Oliver is
playing saw zoo the bird Rafiki is being
played by john connie remember he played
Black Panthers father I feel like he's a
really appropriate choice he did a great
job during that film I feel like he'll
do a great
in this but this is kind of funny Billy
Eichner and Seth Rogen are playing Timon
and Pumbaa Billy Eichner is Timon Seth
Rogen is Pumbaa in the casting for the
hyenas also sounds pretty appropriate
you have keegan-michael Kelley Eric
Andre and then four it's kizomba that
are playing those three if you're
wondering about all the songs and the
musical portions of the film just based
on the way they adapted the live-action
Jungle Book from the animated version
I'm assuming it'll be the exact same
situation so they do most of the big
iconic songs if not all of them there
was a little while ago where they did a
Lion King 1.5 which was an expanded
version of the film they haven't said
anything about putting additional
material and this from the original cut
so I'm just assuming that it will be
based on the original cut if you're not
a big Shakespeare fan the original Lion
King is based on Hamlet uncle kills
father to steal Kingdom son has to
avenge the father can't go wrong when
you're adapting Shakespeare but because
these live-action remakes have done so
gangbusters for Disney there are several
others that they've already announced in
fact we just got a trailer for Aladdin I
didn't do a video for that but this is
the teaser
[Music]
was fall
one of the biggest changes is that Will
Smith will be playing the genie in that
will get another trailer where we
actually hear him speak but the real big
one that they're ramping up for is Mulan
they took a little more time to get that
right I don't know if ming-na wen is
involved with that it would be really
weird if she's not in it maybe she'll be
playing Mulan's mother but I don't think
we're gonna see a trailer for that till
sometime next year Tim Burton just did
Dumbo so if you know Tim Burton films
it's gonna be suitably weird then
there's also supposed to be a Little
Mermaid live-action film that I think
that they postponed but they'll make
that eventually too so pretty much any
iconic Disney animated film imagine them
redoing that in live-action let me know
in the comments though if you grew up on
the animated films what do you think
about all the live-action versions some
of them have genuinely been pretty solid
where you wait for everything click here
to learn what's going on with the
Avengers 4 trailer and click here toward
about Hugh Jackman crossing over with
Deadpool as Wolverine during Marvel
phase 4 thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome and Happy
Thanksgiving
[Music]